this week on brian ross investigates
nothing to be proud about taking on the
proud boys and the oath keepers for what
happened on january 6th
hundreds have already been prosecuted
and now the attorney general in
washington dc is taking them to court
for their money
to hold accountable the proud boys the
oath keepers and more than 30 of their
leaders and members for conspiring to
terrorize the district of columbia
will it make a difference will we ever
find out if the violent extremist had
help from inside congress or inside the
white house
plus the crusading environmental lawyer
sent to prison for refusing to turn over
his computer to chevron has been given
an early release
i'm
thrilled
to be home
i can't explain i i i've been swirling
with emotion you know since i got out
does it change your mind at all about
your stand and refusing to turn over
your devices your background material
electronic devices
to the lawyers for chevron
well that's a great question
and a shout out to the investigative
photojournalist who has made it his
mission to track america's violent
extremist groups courting danger to get
to the truth
from the studios of the law and crime
trial
in new york city's herald square
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and ronda we begin with nothing to be
proud of leaders and members of the
proud boys and the oath keepers are
already facing criminal prosecution for
what happened at the capitol on january
6th and now the attorney general for
washington d.c is taking another attack
going after their money rhonda
that's right brian dc attorney general
carl rassin has filed a civil suit
against both groups seeking financial
damages from them claiming that some
desperately want to rewrite history and
sweep the events of that day under the
rug
but he won't let that happen
the independent office of attorney
general for the district of columbia is
filing the first civil lawsuit by a
state or municipal government to hold
accountable the proud boys the oath
keepers and more than 30 of their
leaders and members for conspiring to
terrorize the district of columbia
for unlawfully interfering with our
country's peaceful transition of power
and for assaulting our men and women in
blue who valiantly defended the capital
the district and our freedoms
and we're joined now by michael
greenberger a law professor and the
founder and director of the center for
health and homeland security at the
university of maryland francis king
kerry school of law and professor
greenberger let me start by asking you
will a lawsuit like this a civil suit
have any impact on these groups
i think it's going to have a very
surprising and impactful uh effect on
these groups
uh
for one thing as you mentioned in the
lead-in
uh the attorney general is seeking money
damages he's not just seeking regular
damages he's seeking punitive damages
and if he's able to prove his case
uh the damages could be so consequential
that the
financial viability of these groups
could
be very seriously in danger
one other advantage of the civil case is
unlike a criminal case
the attorney general here does not have
to prove his case beyond a reasonable
doubt
he only has to show
that what he's trying to prove
is more likely than not
it's a much lower standard and much
easier uh for uh the attorney general to
meet i would also add that our this is
the first elected attorney general in
the district of columbia he's
nearing the end of his second term he's
a very capable experienced litigator so
this
case is in very good hands for the
district of columbia and those the
attorney general is trying to vindicate
and professor where is the federal
government in terms of bringing a
conspiracy charge against these groups
essentially what the attorney general is
doing in civil court
well
the
federal government the justice
department has brought uh
dozens of
civil i'm sorry criminal actions
against the perpetrators
and in fact uh
31 of the
name defendants in the d.c attorney
general's case
uh are either being prosecuted by the
justice department criminally or they
have reached settlement plea plea pled
out their cases
um
in a criminal case a lot of these cases
get pled up the indictment is brought
uh after some procedural
uh
doings the
defendants plead the case
and the public
sees very little about the damage that
was done
uh to the uh capitol police to the
metropolitan police
uh to the members of congress to the
bystanders
in this case
uh attorney general racine is going to
ability to take discovery to get a full
picture of what happened
it will go on there will be
most likely a trial if he survives
initial attempts at uh defending the
case
and it's it will go on for some time
and the public will get a much fuller
picture of the dramatic happenings that
took place on january 6th
unlike the criminal case which will in
most instances end right away with a
plea bargain this case will end up in a
trial it will likely go on for weeks and
there'll be a full exposure
of everything that happened on the sixth
and a full accounting
of the
insurrection and damaging activities
that these groups perpetrated
professor greenberg a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
professor lawsuits for financial damages
are usually brought against corporations
with deep financial pockets this looks
like a ragtag group of folks this is not
really about money is it
well i think it's fair to say racine
make this clear in his press conference
it's not the real reason for bringing
the suit you're quite right these are
ragtag groups uh
the
proud boys tried to
end their
uh legal structure thinking that they
would avoid uh any lawsuits but they are
organized in texas and even when you
shut down you're subject to legal
prosecution
or legal civil suits for three years
uh this is not really about the damages
this is about giving a full
clear picture
aided by full discovery of the
defendants in this case uh and by the
way
the civil complaint here is 88 pages
long
it's extremely detailed it goes minute
by minute uh a
there are the proud boys themselves and
the oath keepers have all these videos
of what they did
minute by minute uh racine is taking
advantage of that discovery which has
taken place in the criminal proceedings
and incorporated them in the civil
proceedings so there's going to be a
very full
vibrant
live accounting
minute by minute of the danger that was
brought to the american people through
this insurrection all right professor
michael greenberger thank you so much
for being with us here tonight later in
the program we'll be joined by the
investigative photojournalist who's been
tracking these groups with his insight
and what they are up to now
up next surprising new developments in
the case of the american lawyer whose
efforts to help people in the amazon
rainforest against a giant oil company
ended up with him in prison you're
watching brian ross investigates on the
long crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
an update now on steve dunsiger the
crusading lawyer whose efforts to help
indigenous people in the amazon
rainforest in ecuador ended up getting
him disbarred and sent to prison for
contempt of court rhonda
brian donziger had refused to turn his
computer over to lawyers for chevron who
had accused him of dishonesty in gaining
a 10 billion dollar verdict in the
courts in ecuador he was sentenced to
six months in prison earlier this year
but in a surprise development he's now
been released and he's back home brian
and we're joined now by stephen dodson
no longer behind bars stephen how did
you get released
i i don't know exactly it's a bit of a
mystery i think the legal authority was
coveted congress allows the bureau of
prisons to release
um people who they think are at risk of
contracting covert
early after serving 25 percent of their
sentence and when i say release brian i
don't be released i'm not free they
release you to home confinement where
you're still under the custody of the
bureau of prisons as i am so i'm not
free i'm just serving out the rest of my
sentence at home
um the prison i was at in danbury was
overcrowded i mean there were a lot of
people there and i think that the prison
officials looking at the fact that i was
literally the only person in the entire
facility
there for a misdemeanor everybody else
was there for the felony they're like
you know my sentence was so short
they probably concluded like why are we
wasting a bet on someone who really
probably shouldn't be here to begin with
even before you went behind bars you had
served almost 800 days on house arrest
you still have another five months or so
i guess does it change your mind at all
about your stand and refusing to turn
over your devices your background
material electronic devices uh to the
lawyers for chevron
well that's a great question um the
short answer is no
but i have done a lot of reflection
about
how this all went down and whether you
know i might have made errors in
judgment on my end
i'll say this i took a principled stand
to protect my clients i don't believe i
did anything wrong i believe i'm
innocent i still have a pending appeal
that i hope to win
um
that said uh you know going forward if
this issue continues i'm going to be
represented by council
and we're going to work our way through
it i have never
taken the position that i would never
turn my computer over to chevron in the
court order that was not the issue the
issue was whether upon turning it over
to chevron privileged information in my
computer would be protected that was the
issue
and you know that's still the issue and
it has to be sort of worked through but
you know obviously i
you know i believe i'm a man of the rule
of law i comply with court orders um you
know as you look back on things that go
down brian you know there's a lot of
things in life i mean if you obviously
if you knew certain things
that you know later you might have done
stuff differently but you know i stand
by my position i think it's the right
position the ethical position i'll
remind people no lawyer ever has been
charged with criminal contempt to court
for what i did which was essentially
taken appeal of a civil discovery
chevron is not letting up though they
still want your devices and they still
have been pushing for you to be behind
bars i guess
well listen this whole idea originated
with chevron i mean this was a
prosecution by a private law firm that
had chevron as a client after the
government refused to prosecute and yeah
you can look at it like hey why didn't
you turn your computer over you know and
that's one way to look at it another way
is like why are you being prosecuted by
a chevron law firm after you won a large
civil judgment on behalf of indigenous
peoples in the amazon against chevron
and i think the latter issue is really
what's important for all americans and
really all people in the world
and of course we should point out that
the prosecutors in the federal
prosecutors in the southern district of
new york declined to prosecute you but
the judge went ahead and appointed this
private lawyer to do just that so and
let me ask you as you sat behind bars up
in danbury uh what were you thinking
well look you know on first of all on a
personal level it's challenging to be in
prison
um
you know it was far more difficult than
i expected frankly i mean it's a low
security prison but because of covet it
was pretty much locked down the whole
time i was there which means we couldn't
we couldn't get out
side
also i'll say this the medical care is
really complicated particularly the age
of coba i was worried i'm 60 years old
that if i got sick
you know it would be
not a good place not a good thing not
the right place for me and i really
wanted to get out of there and
as soon as i could and i'm thankful and
grateful to the bureau of prisons that
they made the decision that they did
which i think was based on policy and
was appropriate
the point of contempt of court and
sending you to prison obviously was to
try to break you to get you to comply
with the court order are you broken now
first of all i'm definitely not broken i
mean i'm um we're going to continue to
fight on there's so many lawyers from
around the world who called me to join
our team where i think we're as strong
as ever
partly as a result of what i would call
this overreach you know putting an
american human rights lawyer in prison
in terms of holding chevron accountable
for its pollution in the amazon which is
what drove me to work on this issue
you know there's still work to do we're
not broken to the contrary we're going
to keep moving forward until they pay
the judgment and the indigenous peoples
in the amazon can have their ancestral
lands restored and they can you know get
what they deserve which is compensation
for the harm caused them as ordered by
various courts around the world
and let me have you respond your chevron
continues to maintain allegedly you
bribed a judge you presented fabricated
evidence they didn't like your tactics
at all and in fact the judgment you
received in ecuador i guess has been
upended in this country
well look this these are the facts i'm
sure i disagree with chevron's view
obviously we've been at loggerheads for
years um you know we meaning me and
other group other lawyers on behalf of
these indigenous peoples won a 10
billion dollar pollution judgment after
an eight-year trial that has been
affirmed by ecuador supreme court it's
been a firm for enforcement purposes by
canada's supreme court and all 28
appellate judges there's one judge in
the u.s that they always cite judge
kaplan who ruled against me after a
non-jury trial where they paid a witness
to claim i bribed a judge it didn't
happen it's been rejected by 28
appellate judges in other countries it
did not happen definitely did not happen
no it didn't there was no bribery of a
judge
they paid a witness to say that about me
but it did not happen there's no
corroborating evidence
judges serious judges all over the world
have looked at this and rejected it
so you know it's just not true
now it is a judicial ruling here by this
one judge and they try to play on it
constantly when they give statements to
journalists but it's simply not true the
judgment is legitimate it's been
affirmed by six different appellate
courts and it's owned by the it's not my
judgment it's the judgment of the people
of ecuador they have lawyers and their
intention as i understand it is to make
sure that judgment is enforced so the
money is paid and chevron is forced to
comply with the rule of law
and finally just to uh how are you doing
now out of prison back with your family
for the holidays how are you doing
personally i'm um
thrilled
to be home
um i i can't explain it i i've been
swirling with emotion you know since i
got out
um i've been
i felt i i realized how much pain i
carried out of that prison i i mean the
experiences to see so many people hurt
inside and to come out see my family was
hurting
and i'll say this you know
going into prison is often is harder on
the people who love you on the outside
than it is on you on the inside i've
realized that a lot of people told me
that it's really true
you know i could at least control to an
extent what i did inside you know but
when you're outside you're like oh my
god what's going on is he you know
there's no communication you know is he
even sleeping and i can tell you i
didn't have one decent night's sleep in
45 days it was it was
really unsettling
i do want to acknowledge though that
it's you know i met a lot of strong
people in prison who who you know i
learned from them how they handled the
time and my sentence obviously was
ridiculously short compared to most
people
um but to me it felt like an eternity
i'm i'm really happy to be home and i'm
happy to be with my family and i'm happy
to be able to
speak again to people like you so thank
you for asking
all right stephen danzano thank you so
much for being with us again be here
tonight
thank you
up next inside the proud boys and the
oath keepers in america's other violent
extremist groups will be joined by the
photojournalist who has been tracking
them you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime trial
network tonight a media shout out for
the investigative photojournalist who's
made it his mission to track the
emergence of america's violent extremist
groups a dangerous job but that's just
what zach roberts has been doing again
and again zach thanks for joining us
tonight these are crazy people and your
family must think you're crazy to be
dealing with them
uh yes uh it's taken uh
many years and i'm still not quite sure
if my uh like my mother understands
exactly what i do or more specifically
why i do it because she knows that
um it's not financially benefiting like
just journalism in general as we all
know is not exactly the greatest you
know financial move
when you're inside these groups and
dealing with them do they come across to
you as having intelligence are they
scheming what what gives with these
groups
i mean most i mean it really depends on
kind of which group you're talking about
but like the groups you know we were
talking about because of this uh lawsuit
today um you know the oath keepers and
the proud boys it's a full range of guys
who just want to hang out with other
men and and get into fights and also
commit a little bit of racism now now
and then um but um but yeah no i mean i
don't think that usually there's that
many great schemers um you know outside
of patriot front which is the group that
you're seeing they they definitely do a
lot of planning sessions um and they're
very particular about the clothing that
they wear the flags that they think how
they look you know and they're they're
they're kind of uh the way that they
look to the rest of society and you know
really big thing is it's looking scary
um the proud boys while they're a
violent um
western chauvinist gang um who has
committed multiple
dozens of acts of violence across the
country and have really never really
been held to task outside of a handful
of people in new york city and a couple
other places um
they they're not planning for anything
big usually um but as we can see in this
lawsuit
that the attorney general of d.c just
dropped
uh they they planned and they conspired
with um with uh with each other to
commit a lot of the violence uh that you
saw on january 6.
we know they're disdain for the media
how do they treat you we've just got 30
seconds here
again i mean it fully arranges some some
people they really want their photos
taken um and they play into the cameras
and other people you get physical
threats um i've had colleagues of mine
who have had equipment destroyed been
attacked um by by all these groups and
uh and so every single time you talk to
somebody it's kind of up in the air on
whether or not you're going to get
punched in the face or smiled all right
a shout out to zach roberts a job well
done zach thanks so much for being here
tonight
thank you for having me and that's our
program for tonight i want to thank you
so much for joining us and wish all of
you a very happy holiday and a happy
holiday and a big thanks for the great
crew here at the law and crime network
for great work throughout the year have
a good night
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you